I don't know a single person that goes
to church come on that's where it comes
from
oh really yeah are you [ __ ] English
right trust me I'm from that I don't
know a single [ __ ] person that goes
to church you gotta be kidding me
right God you know why because it's all
a made-up load of nonsense I know that
already we've realized that already I
don't know a single person that goes to
church
yes swear to God England yeah bowling
apart oh my god I'm exaggerating a
little bit but but in terms of not
knowing a single person that goes to
church but do you know what a single
person it had because America is still a
young country yeah and we don't I don't
know if that's the reason but certainly
religion is that much much bigger like a
look at look at countries though that's
been around for way longer than America
their views on sex is completely
different they're more open to it
what yes I'm only talking about first
world countries oh okay you know I
honestly and I and I come across like an
elitist piece of [ __ ] talking about
other open wound and I want to say
sleepers and I'm being completely honest
with you okay I a lot of times I could
do my shows and I have all kinds of
people come and I love everybody okay I
don't when I call junglu certain Asians
jungle Asians I don't mean it yeah I
don't mean it in a derogatory way I love
you okay
go [ __ ] yourself that's you know I've
learned so much from you because in my
head I'm like everybody says like wow if
you had the English so insightful
now I'm being real though like the
church thing it was like yeah well no
it'sit's it doesn't play a big factor
honestly everybody I know they go to
church for two reasons when for
christening and they don't believe in
God every just cause it gets hammered
it's a party you know get dressed up and
celebrate the birth of the child but
it's not really a religious thing or a
wedding you know and the same thing
again and with our children my wife she
didn't want to have a christening I'm
like come on look at the kids christen
yeah she said well no we're not
religious I'm like yeah technically a
Catholic everybody has a christening and
one and she's like no and I thought
about I thought no I actually respect
what you say no you're right we
shouldn't do that we be hypocrites so so
we never did that but genuinely that's
all people do in England but do you
believe in God no I don't I I wish I did
I'm sure it's a lovely feeling I'm sure
it makes you feel a nice warm and fuzzy
inside and I would love to think that
when I die I go up there to a nice
beautiful little place yeah called
heaven and all my loved ones are there I
would love that I would love that and
it's weird that in times of loss perhaps
you do obviously I share the exact same
sentiment I know that you think about
these things when I say religious people
and I see them really like you know they
leave it up to somebody else
I always just I can imagine what a great
feeling that is but I just don't have I
wish I did and another say I mean I you
know I bust balls I respect them and I
try and try and not be offensive
yeah because if I said what I really
thought I'd be I would offend them I
don't understand how you can honestly
believe that there's a man up there the
worst thing is [ __ ] MMA fighters okay
number one if there is a God you think
he gives a [ __ ] about this little pet
MMA fight
yeah he's got bigger things to do this
[ __ ] earthquakes and tsunamis happen
all ohh laughter but no I'm gonna take
time out there to make sure a [ __ ]
dick weasel from Brazil wins he's fine
Romero he is what right
oh yeah big time big time Ben Hansen
it's yeah it's it's my least favorite
words are first and foremost first and
foremost but you know like us
you know who really believes in God is
that kid that we just saw what say he
fought max Holloway what's his name yeah
Brian will take his very religious and
after every match he goes I want to
thank Jesus or yes it happened on the
night I lost I know that night when his
face [ __ ] right everybody
daddy max get in pray hard enough you
know why cuz max Holloway's name is
blessed still God favored him
last year what a fighter huh he's being
amazing one of the most responsible
thing I ever heard of anybody is when
you call that max yeah we talked about
that yeah my family's and has a medical
background right and when they heard
that they told me they're like look he
actually pointed it out when no one else
would
yeah it was weird because I mean I I've
had a lot of injuries throughout my
fight career and if I was training for a
fight and somebody called me out on live
TV about one of my injuries I'd be
pissed
you know because you train and you want
to fight you want to get paid you've
done all that hard work as I say you
want to get paid so we were doing UFC to
nine we have a production meeting and of
course you know we go over the questions
what we're gonna ask so we have cards
there and we're doing the interview and
he's slurring his words and he's all
over the place and I'm like [ __ ] what he
says on the cards I'm like yo max you
got that buddy yeah Am I cuz you sound
like you're half-asleep and anyway I
flew to Vegas that night to cover the
fight and when I got to Vegas I started
getting tweets and messages
fights off maximum pulled from the card
I'm like oh [ __ ] I hope I wasn't the
catalyst of that so I text him I said
listen max I'm sorry man and he text
back said no thank you thank you he said
I needed somebody to say that you know
all right all right well I appreciate
that but what was it though do you know
you just had a concussion you know the
hard thing is you know mixed martial
arts you got a train the way you fight
so you know you train hard you spar hard
you get hit you know it's it's a shame
it is but he's good yeah yeah all good
he came back
[Music]